i did want to play the game robin this
is uh where uh you will be called on
robin for your skills in deducing who
got caught masturbating
the big fear is getting caught jerking
off and it's actually happened to
several members of my staff and i
thought it'd be a fun game robin i'll
give you the names of the people
participating will murray who is a
wonderful head writer richard christie
you know richard sal gubinale who you
know
who doesn't uh chris wiley explanation
yes
jason kaplan who's an executive producer
on the show and uh ronnie mund who was
uh
many years ahead of security
roundtable of creeps welcome
ed
creeps what is it high pitch i'm in the
middle of a routine here what are you
doing hey howard howard could i play
along with robin
uh-huh all right okay i'll let you play
along we'll see how well you do you
versus right don't you dare beat me at
this hybrid don't win okay
i'm feeling he will
all right high pitch all right robin
here we go it's time for
i've been caught masturbating
they got caught masturbating oh man
all right
here we go in honor of national
masturbation day on may 7th oh i didn't
even know there was one
man either
well now you know
you have something in common with high
pitch you both don't know it's
masturbation there you go i'm worried
now about myself all right person number
one was listen carefully all you lose
a person number one was caught jerking
off with his friend in the same room
when they were teenagers
he and his friend used to watch their
neighbors having sex through the window
they would get all worked up
and then jerk off together in separate
beds
one day
the friend's older brother walked in on
them fully aroused oh
they didn't even hear him open the door
he was 15 years old when this happened
so he had pubic hair and a full
masculine boner
i would have to say ronnie because he's
older and yeah he must have a lot of
pubic hair
oh
[Music]
leave it alone all right
i'm gonna say it's richard
all right so robin you say richard
christie i'm gonna lock you in
and i'm gonna lock in high pitch with
ronnie
and now for the big reveal here we go
everybody the answer is oh robin go you
better make like an ostrich and stick
your head in the sand it's ronnie j mine
oh that's great
well i didn't think about his pubic hair
of course
well maybe you ought to dumb it down a
little
eric you are on the scoreboard with one
point
oh my god ronnie what happened we opened
up pants
and we had our pants down you know just
enough for your dick to come out
and we were laying there jerking
thinking about we would take out his
brothers his brother used to hide his
playboy magazines
in a drawer in the desk and we we found
him like he thought we didn't know they
were there so we would find you know we
would watch this [ __ ] going on then we
would find his magazines
and we'd be laying there in the bed
jerking off and one day he came home
from work and there he you know we're
[ __ ] laying there both jerking off
every movie i watch
would you ever watch him jerking off
well you couldn't help but watch i mean
you know when you're done you know if
you're done first and you you know
you get up or whatever
there he is you know whacking his thing
and what did the brother say when he
walked in and you two wackos are
whacking off we just start we just
started [ __ ] laughing and you know
he got he got mad that we were in we
were in his desk and found this [ __ ]
magazine
everyone loves the caught masturbating
game
they got caught masturbating oh man man
this is fun all right
all right that's one for high pitch and
nothing for me
all right this maniac from my staff was
caught jerking off by his kid his own
child
no no no no no
robin you're getting too emotional you
put on your thinking that's what your
problem is
robin gets caught up in these stories
you notice eric is quiet he's listening
robin's coming stop laughing peter
he's gonna try and take this seriously
he's trying to
yeah yeah all right this staffer was
caught jerking off by his own child
while they were on vacation last summer
as a goof
his kid
and his cousin were bursting into all
the rooms all over the house
of course
they burst into the room
while our staffer was rubbing one out
he thinks he covered up enough but he's
not sure
hopefully it didn't scar his kid for
life
which staffer was it jason was it will
was it richard was it chris was it sal
or of course we know it's not ronnie
he's eliminated
all right who wants to go first uh
i don't know of uh but i should go first
because he went first last though oh i
don't know if you're having children
you know i don't know
[Laughter]
he's he's pretending to be gay because
he needed a gay person on the show i
have a family and a wife
all right well robin jason doesn't have
children
that leaves
you know two of the biggest creeps sal
and richard and then
of course will
well so
this would be most surprising
if it was will
so what is your answer
[Music]
was it sal in your opinion richard
well or maybe someone else has a secret
kid we don't know all right well i'm
going with the ones i don't have kids
all right i'm gonna say will
will all right i'm gonna write down the
word will
how do you spell that w-i-l-l i believe
[Laughter]
uh hi pitch what about you do you agree
with robin that it's will or do you
think it's one of the other perverts i
don't agree with robin i have i would
have to see sal because south kids are
older than
will's kids don't have to go with sal's
kid
all right you're on a bit of a roll on
the right downstairs yeah he could be
the one who knows
what situations these guys would be
caught in
the pervert who was caught
jerking off by his own child was
oh yeah
that's well
on the scoreboard
and congratulations first of all to will
who wins a lifetime supply of therapy
for his son well what happened
i mean that you heard the story that's
exactly how it went down
they were being maniacs running into
rooms and like he burst in and i
screamed it was like get out of here get
out of here try and cover it up the best
i could but
first of all why are you now why are you
not locking the door
there's no locks on the doors of this
place it was and of course i would have
otherwise but yeah there was no locks no
i should have leaned up against the door
now how do you masturbate do you lay
down or do you i was laying in a bed i
was laying in a bed
and like i said i tried to put up my
legs
[Laughter]
well all right will uh there's still
more questions i have but i in the
excitement we don't want to miss the
rest of the game so uh let me recap the
score it is one to one high pitch has
one and robin has one
as we continue to play the caught
masturbating game that everybody seems
to love and enjoy
they got caught masturbating oh man
this next staffer
was caught beating off inside a giant
toy box by his mother
wait a minute what are you talking about
he was listening inside the toy box this
is why you're to lose you're asking too
many because you've got to listen
just pay attention and listen
here we go
she's getting all charged up and she
going she's going to no i just have to
know were they
parents at the time or were they
let me let me let me talk and let me get
out the story for you all right
all right this staffer was caught
beating off inside a giant toy box by
his mother
one afternoon in junior high
okay
when you're too old to be in a toy box
well we're gonna get to that
one afternoon in junior high he was
beating off in his toy box
and he heard the bedroom door open
his mom yelled
where are you
he put his underwear back on while
inside the toy box and opened the lid
[Music]
listen you were jerking off with your
friend
shut up ronnie yeah you have no room to
talk
his mom said
what the hell are you doing in there
drugs
he said he hoped it was drugs
he
he answered her
yes because she didn't want her to know
he was beating off
they never spoke of it again
this guy jerks off like david blaine the
magician he's in a box
locked inside all right let's see who's
left
we know it's not well and we know it's
not ronnie was it jason kaplan was it
richard christie
was it chris wilding
or sal gabinelli
of you go ahead hi [ __ ] what are your
thoughts i would say
wicked loves toys and saddles toys
so in this case i always have to go with
richard christie
all right okay
some uh dull logic there he says
richard loves choice
and therefore it has to be richard who
was jerking off in the toy box robin
what's your logic
huh
i don't know much about chris's family
background chris wilding so that i could
make some determination about what his
mom might do
or how his mom was with him
i really don't think he had a toy box in
junior high school
i think he was more sophisticated than
that oh thank you okay
so i'm going to say
[Music]
it's jason
jason kaplan all right i'm gonna lock
you in
all right so he was not sophisticated
toys right behind me right now
rob he does he does have
robin you say it's jason kaplan who was
caught masturbating in a toy box yes and
uh high pitch you say richard christie
well
it's time for the big reveal in the got
caught masturbating game and the winner
of this particular segment is
high pitcher oh yeah are you kidding me
richard christie the dull logic wins
again
[Music]
robin
richard you are uh
the masturbator who was in a toy box
tell us about this story if you can
elaborate on it
well yeah i had a giant wooden toy box
and you know i was even in junior high
still on the monster toys and wrestling
toys and i believe masters magazine oh i
should have thought of that of course
robin but but the reason i would hide in
there is because i had a neighbor who
was really into like the rambo movies
and him and and his friend
they put camouflage on at night and
peek into my bedroom window and scare
the [ __ ] out of me and i was always
terrified that this neighbor that loved
rambo was gonna be peeking in my window
and i'm jerking off so i'd open up this
giant toy box i'd throw out all the toys
real quick i jump in there
take my clothes off take my underwear
off and just beat off in complete
darkness in the toy box knowing that
nobody could see me but then
my mom needed something one day and i
heard the door open and i freaked out
i'm like oh my god
you were nude you were nude in the toy
box totally nude but i had my underwear
in there with me i had climbed in in my
underwear
and uh ah i was like do i just tell you
this place this toy box sounds bigger
than my first apartment
like half my room it was
huge uh but i was like should i stay in
here until my mom leaves but then she
wouldn't leave like
and finally i was like i opened up the
it was must have been like dracula
opening up his coffin
the lid slowly opens up and i'm in my
underwear and she's like what are you
doing in there
and she goes are you doing drugs because
at the time like grass was a big thing
you know just say no and all that and i
was like yeah yeah i was doing drugs i'm
sorry there was no evidence of drugs
though no no
there was a white substance but it
wasn't drug exactly
he snorted his [ __ ] to make his mind
oh my god what a story ronnie what do
you make of this story uh i mean uh
you've seen all kinds of perversion but
this is insane right that's insane man
i can't stop [ __ ] where'd you come oh
i didn't that i was done after that no
but where normally where would you come
oh right on the the you're in the
freaking dock in there the floor of the
toy box it was all oh oh
can you just put your toys
imagine you're such you're such an
animal that your mom's praying you're
doing drugs in the toy box
wow eric i'm gonna tell you something
right now
yeah and i mean this
this who got caught masturbating game is
your game uh the lower your i2 the
higher struggling i'm struggling
the lower your iq the higher your score
and that's what we're learning for this
game so uh eric is robin you are
struggling that is correct
eric's like the ken jennings of this
game
[Laughter]
eric is like the ken jennings of who got
caught masturbating robin being down two
to one to eric all right this next human
being if you want to call him that
ejaculated with his mom in the room
this maniac shared a computer in his
room
his mom walked in just as he was coming
he had to lie there and finish coming
under the blankets while his mom used
the computer less than a foot away
after that
he put a lock on his door
i'm saying this is sal
hi pitch what do you say do you think
it's sal or do you think it's one of the
other two jason or chris
i don't think it's sad because that was
more freakier than that
more freakier than jerking off with his
mother
more freaky
yeah go ahead
he's on a roll leave him alone
yeah he knows more than i do so it has
to be either between jason and chris
and chris is more freaky than jason so i
would have to say jason campbell
jason kaplan all right
it's gonna be good
yeah i mean if uh oh if you lose this
one robin it could be i'm in trouble i'm
really in deep deep trouble
do we wanna know if
high pitch is right it's jason or is
robin i'm quitting my pitch is right
again
you're not allowed to quit
and robin you said sal
the pervert is
oh yeah wow
chris wilding was the
committed mild and says first of all uh
both of you were wrong thank god robin
because you're still in the game oh my
god both are wrong it was chris wilding
first of all rob and i would think
sal would never be under a blanket
masturbating
sophisticated he's gonna jerk off on a
bus robin come on
i mean come on
the dead giveaway was he was under the
blanket i mean my god
am i supposed to know that
yes
of course you are you want to be in the
fbi you're never going to make it
all right now the masturbation game
is continuing and now it comes down to
everything
you were wrong too high pitch
yeah
you think you know so much
now this one is interesting he wasn't
technically
caught jerking off
this very thirsty pervert
accidentally [ __ ] into his own soda
when he was nearly caught beating off
now here's what happened
he was jerking off at his desk while his
wife was out
when his wife returned home unexpectedly
he jumped up
and finished all over his desk
he cleaned
he cleaned up the mess before she came
into the room
a few minutes later he took a sip of his
soda and thought it tasted weird
he looked in the cup and noticed some of
his jizz was floating in
this pervert
drank his own jism
it's only down between two perverts
jason kaplan and sal gabanel
and uh i believe
we're gonna go to high pitch first
all right
mmm
wow what an interesting slow thought
process yes but certainly pervy
all right that's a good guess let's go
to robin quivers is she going to take
the strategy to go opposite high pitch
or will she vote with him
i don't know let's see
he picked jason
that's right robert
let's whisper at this point so it sounds
more important than it
that's the question
because there's
hmm
i think i'm i'm not piggybacking
off right
high pitch
[Music]
but i'm going with jason too
all right those are two jasons i'm gonna
write that down
and now for the reveal both of you said
jason kaplan
and your answer is
100
wrong
oh wow
it was sal who got his own jizz in his
own soda and drank it sal
congratulations on another horrible
story in your life
for the course how'd it taste it tasted
salty that was the odd thing about it
[Laughter]
you know what it was robin i i got a
large squirt from
i got a large coke from blimpies and
i'll never forget it the straw was
broken so i took the lid off if i've
never taken the lid off i never would
have [ __ ] inside my soda
so yeah i was
mid-loaded i jumped up and it went
everywhere and i was like i got away
with this and then i relaxed i went for
the soda i went to sip it but i go what
this just tastes really weird and i
looked down and it was just this clumpy
stuff on floating there
i had a little ball of jizz on my
tongue out
all right there you go well um there was
only one more story it was jason's story
uh high pitched wins because yeah
because he went ahead of me
uh robin it's a sad day
all my money was on you well i really
don't feel bad about losing this kind of
contest i don't know how pervy these
guys are you know don't diminish the
game feel bad
think of them as as being above all this
but you know and then i have this
reality and by the way i do want to
mention jason's pervy story uh this guy
yes what did we not reveal about jake
jason fell asleep completely naked after
masturbating and was caught by his wife
with porn still playing on the ipad
it was like waking up after a bomb went
off i'm just
my bed the covers are off naked porn
playing on the ipad i thought maybe i
got away with something yeah and this is
when you were at your heaviest right oh
yeah 305 pounds of just probably i
thought you were dead
i wish she had taken a picture of that
one
well high pitch you're a winner and uh
today you're a winner i can't say i in
fact it's the first time i've ever said
that
they got caught masturbating oh man